It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是盛花期，我的业务正飞速扩张。为了让蜂蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧嚣热闹，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. in your high school yearbook, you'll probably recognize many of the faces of your classmates, even if you haven't seen them in years. That might seem like a uniquely human ability, but recent research with chimpanzees and bonobos has found that they too can recognize individuals even after spending many years apart. Today we're going to talk with a researcher who studies these great apes about how humans' closest relatives navigate their social world. So how closely are we related to these non-human primates?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会受到数据流量降速的影响。在你高中的年鉴里，你很可能会认出许多同学的脸，即使你们已经多年未见。这似乎是一种人类独有的能力，但最近对黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩的研究发现，它们在分开多年后也能认出个体。今天，我们将与一位研究这些大型类人猿的研究人员探讨人类最近的亲属是如何在它们的社会世界中导航的。那么，我们与这些非人类灵长类动物的亲缘关系有多近呢？
What else can they do that might surprise us? What catches their attention in the social world? And what can their behavior teach us about the evolution of human social intelligence? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Laura Simone Lewis, an assistant professor in the departments of psychological and brain sciences and anthropology
它们还会做什么可能会让我们感到惊讶的事情？在社会世界中，什么能引起它们的注意？它们的行为能教给我们关于人类社会智能演化的什么知识？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是劳拉·西蒙妮·刘易斯（Laura Simone Lewis）博士，她是加利福尼亚大学圣巴巴拉分校心理与大脑科学系以及人类学系的助理教授。
at the University of California's Santa Barbara. She studies social cognition in bonobos and chimpanzees, including how these great apes form, build, maintain, and repair their long-term social relationships. Her research findings have been published in peer-reviewed journals and covered in media outlets, including Scientific American, NPR, the Washington Post, and the New York Times. Dr. Lewis, thanks for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. It's a joy to be here. I'd like to start with some context.
她研究倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩的社会认知，包括这些大型类人猿如何形成、建立、维持和修复其长期的社会关系。她的研究成果已发表在同行评审的期刊上，并被《科学美国人》、《NPR》、《华盛顿邮报》和《纽约时报》等媒体报道。刘易斯博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。我想从一些背景开始。
You study, as I said, you study chimpanzees and bonobos. Where do they fall on the evolutionary tree? That's right. So I study chimpanzees and bonobos who are both our closest living phylogenetic relatives. So we share, humans share a last common ancestor with them that lived somewhere between five, to nine million years ago. The numbers change all the time, but somewhere between five to nine million years ago. And when I say we share a last common ancestor with them, the way I like to think about it is that last common ancestor that we share that lived five of a million years ago is not
正如我所说，您研究黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩。它们在演化树上处于什么位置？没错。我研究的黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩都是我们现存最近的系统发生亲属。因此，人类与它们共享一个生活在大约五百万到九百万年前的最近共同祖先。数字一直在变，但大约在五百万到九百万年前。当我说我们与它们共享一个最近共同祖先时，我的理解方式是，我们共享的那个生活在数百万年前的最近共同祖先……
alive today. So I like to think of this last common ancestor as our great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great grandma. And five million years ago sounds like a ton of time, and it is, you know, but in terms of our evolutionary history and the age of the earth, it's actually just a blip in evolutionary time, which means that we are extremely closely related to them. We share almost 99% of our DNA with them. And it means also we have a lot of similarities in terms of our psychology and especially our social psychology, which is what we study. Of course, there's many differences as well. And it's these similarities and differences in our social psychology that I explore in order to think about kind of our evolutionary history.
今天并不在世。所以我喜欢把这个最近共同祖先想象成我们的曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾祖母。五百万年前听起来是一段漫长的时间，确实也是，你知道的，但就我们的演化史和地球年龄而言，它其实只是演化时间中的转瞬即逝的一瞬间，这意味着我们与它们有着极其紧密的亲缘关系。我们与它们共享近 99% 的DNA。这也意味着我们在心理学，尤其是我们所研究的社会心理学方面有许多相似之处。当然，也有许多不同之处。我正是探索我们社会心理学中的这些相似之处与不同之处，来思考某种程度上的演化史。
and our shared evolutionary history. Now, one of your best-known findings, which I mentioned in my introduction a moment ago, is that chimps and bonobos can recognize former groupmates even after many years apart. So can you walk us through how you tested that and what you found? Absolutely. Let me start by talking about what we know in ourselves as humans. We have remarkable long-term memory. And as you mentioned in your intro, we could pick up a yearbook from 30 years ago.
以及我们共同的演化史。现在，你最著名的发现之一——我在刚才的开场白中提到过——是黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩即使在分开多年后，也能认出以前的同群伙伴。那么，你能带我们了解一下你是如何测试这一点的以及你发现了什么吗？当然可以。让我先从我们人类自身的情况谈起。我们拥有非凡的长期记忆。正如你在开场白中提到的，我们可以拿起一本30年前的年鉴……
and look through that yearbook and recognize the faces of our classmates, even if we haven't seen them or seen a picture of them in 30 years. And the other thing we know about our own human memory is that our memory, our long-term memory for others, is shaped by our social relationships and social roles. So we remember others in clusters based on our previous relationships with them. So first, that's what we know already about human long-term memory. And what we didn't know is that is whether, and to what extent, chimpanzees and bonobos could remember the faces of their previous groupmates and for how long, and whether their social relationships also shaped their long-term social memory. So this is how we came to think about designing a study around long-term social memory.
翻看那本年鉴，认出我们同学的脸，即使我们已经30年没见过他们或他们的照片了。关于我们人类记忆的另一件事是，我们对他人的长期记忆是由我们的社会关系和社会角色塑造的。因此，我们根据以前与他们的关系，将其他人归类记忆。首先，这就是我们对人类长期记忆的已知了解。而我们过去不知道的是，黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩是否以及在多大程度上能够记住以前同群伙伴的脸，能记住多久，以及它们的社会关系是否也塑造了它们的长期社会记忆。这就是我们开始构思围绕长期社会记忆设计研究的原因。
And I just want to give you a few anecdotes before we jump into the details of the study, which is that As researchers who work with great apes, these are very precious and endangered populations, and we often have to travel around the world to get to work with these populations. And what researchers noticed when they would travel back and forth to go study these great eight populations is that it seems like the great apes we studied would remember us year after year, even if we hadn't been there in a year or two to that site or that population. They expressed what seemed like behaviors that indicated they remembered us, even if they hadn't seen us in years. And so we wanted to go test this idea.
在深入研究细节之前，我想先分享几个轶事：作为与大型类人猿共事的研究人员，它们是非常珍贵且濒危的种群，我们经常需要周游世界去研究这些种群。研究人员在往返研究这些大型类人猿种群时注意到，我们研究过的大型类人猿似乎每年都能认出我们，即使我们有一两年没有去过那个地点或那个种群。它们表现出似乎表明它们记得我们的行为，即使它们已经几年没见我们了。所以我们想去测试这个想法。
So that's how we kind of came up with this study idea, and it was based on anecdotally what Great Abe researchers had been noticing. And we really wanted to get some data to find this out. So how we designed the study is this is a non-invasive eye-tracking study with chimpanzees and bonobos, non-invasive, meaning it's not harmful at all to the animals. And eye tracking, meaning we use an eye tracker in order to determine where on a screen chimpanzees and bonobos are looking at any given time. So in this way, we can show two different pictures on a screen, and the eye tracker sits directly below the screen, and it records how long gonelboes and chimpanzees are looking at one image
这就是我们想出这个研究想法的由来，它基于大型类人猿研究人员历来注意到的轶事。我们真的很想获得一些数据来弄清楚这一点。我们设计这项研究的方法是：这是一项针对黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩的非侵入式眼动追踪研究，“非侵入式”意味着对动物完全没有伤害。而“眼动追踪”意味着我们使用眼动仪来确定黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩在任何特定时间看着屏幕的哪个位置。通过这种方式，我们可以在屏幕上显示两张不同的图片，眼动仪直接位于屏幕下方，它记录黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩看一幅图像的时长……
over the other. So in this way we designed a pretty simple study. The study design itself was pretty simple. We showed one picture of a previous groupmate who they hadn't seen in years, and one picture of a complete stranger. And what we found is that both chimpanzees and bonobos looked significantly longer at these images of their previous groupmates as compared to the images of the strangers. And then we also added one more detail where we were.
超过另一幅图像。通过这种方式，我们设计了一个相当简单的研究。研究设计本身相当简单。我们展示了一张它们多年未见的以前同群伙伴的照片，以及一张完全陌生者的照片。我们发现，黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩注视以前同群伙伴图像的时间，显著长于注视陌生者图像的时间。然后我们还增加了一个细节：
We surveyed the keepers who were working with these chimpanzees and bonobos who are living in zoos and sanctuaries. We surveyed them about the participants in our study and their previous relationships with the previous groupmates who they were seeing in the images. We asked them what was the social relationship like? What were the rates of negative social interactions between the participants and the previous groupmates? What were the rates of positive social interactions? and what was the relative dominance between the participants in our study and the previous groupmates who they were seeing on the screen. We found something fascinating here,
我们调查了在这些生活在动物园和庇护所的黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩身边的饲养员。我们向他们调查了我们研究的参与者，以及他们与图片中看到的以前同群伙伴的关系。我们问他们社会关系是怎样的？参与者与以前同群伙伴之间的消极社会互动频率是多少？积极社会互动的频率是多少？我们研究中的参与者与他们在屏幕上看到的以前同群伙伴之间的相对统治地位如何。我们在这里发现了一个迷人的现象，
which is that chimpanzees and bonobos looked even longer, significantly longer, at images of previous groupmates with whom they had higher rates of positive social interactions, or whom I might call their previous friends. So we think what we're seeing here is there's some distinction in their attention, where they're paying even more attention to their previous friends. And the last thing I'll note about this study is that we had a bonobo Louise who hadn't seen her sister and her nephew for almost 27 years. Now, we couldn't collect a ton of data from Louise.
那就是黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩注视那些与它们有更多积极社会互动的以前同群伙伴的图像的时间更长，显著更长，或者我称之为它们以前的朋友。所以我们认为在这里看到的是，它们的注意力有所区别，它们对以前的朋友给予了更多的关注。关于这项研究，我要指出的最后一点是，我们有一只名叫露易丝（Louise）的倭黑猩猩，她有将近27年没见过她的姐姐和外甥了。现在，我们无法从露易丝那里收集大量数据。
We had a few trials from Louise, so we couldn't analyze them on their own. But what we noticed, and in our plots when we plotted this data, we found that Louise was looking a lot longer at the images of her sister and her nephew who she hadn't seen in 27 years. And we think that this indicates that she may have some recognition of her sister and her nephew for almost three decades, which is very similar to our own human memory and really remarkable. And I would say the longest long-term social memory ever found in an animal. species besides humans. Wow. Well, what do you
我们从露易丝那里得到了几次试验数据，所以我们无法单独分析它们。但是我们注意到，在我们绘制这些数据的图表中，我们发现露易丝注视她27年未见的姐姐和外甥图像的时间要长得多。我们认为这表明她可能对她的姐姐和外甥保留了近三十年的某种记忆，这与我们人类自身的记忆非常相似，而且确实非常了不起。我想说，这是人类以外的动物物种中发现的最长的长期社会记忆。哇。那么，你认为这……
think this means for how we treat animals in captivity? I mean, I don't want to anthropomorphize this too much, but did Louise maybe miss her sister and her nephew the same way we humans would? It's a great
对我们如何对待圈养动物意味着什么？我的意思是，我不想把这拟人化得太严重，但露易丝会不会像我们人类那样想念她的姐姐和外甥呢？这是一个很好的……
question, and I think I have to say, we don't know. And I think this is an area that is rich for further exploration. And I hope graduate students in lab will be able to explore this question further is what is the nature of those memories look like? Do they come with emotions, right, that we humans feel when we think about previous social partners? What is the nature of those memories in terms of the content?
问题，我想我不得不说，我们不知道。我认为这是一个值得进一步探索的领域。我希望实验室的研究生能够进一步探索这个问题：这些记忆的本质是什么？当我们想到以前的社会伙伴时，它们是否伴随着我们人类感受到的那种情感？就内容而言，这些记忆的本质是什么？
Do they remember, for example, grooming with their previous groupmates or getting into conflicts with their previous group mates? We don't know that yet. It's something that we still have to test. I would assume, and hypothesize that they do remember they have a fuller, richer content in their memories of these individuals rather than lower level, just simple recognition. But it's something that we have to explore. And we're designing studies now to try and get at that question. It's interesting that they could recognize former groupmates or family members from photos. I mean, a lot of animals don't understand photos at all. You can show a picture of a dog to your dog. My dog is down here. If I showed her a picture of a dog, it'd be like, what the hell?
例如，它们是否记得与以前的同群伙伴梳理毛发，或者与以前的同群伙伴发生冲突？我们还不知道。这是我们仍然必须测试的东西。我会假设并推测它们确实记得，在它们对这些个体的记忆中，有着更饱满、更丰富的内容，而不仅仅是较低水平的简单识别。但这是我们必须探索的东西。我们现在正在设计研究来试图弄清这个问题。有趣的是，它们可以通过照片认出以前的同群伙伴或家庭成员。我的意思是，很多动物根本不理解照片。你可以给你的狗看一张狗的照片。我的狗就在下面。如果我给她看一张狗的照片，她会觉得，这到底是什么鬼？
But how is it that these great apes actually can understand what they're seeing is another bonobo or chimp? Absolutely. Well, with the first eye-tracking studies with great apes, a mentor and colleague and collaborator of mine, Dr. Fumuhirocano, in his first studies with eye-tracking with great apes, he found that chimpanzees and bonobos look at images of others in a similar way to humans. So they focus a lot on the eye regions and the mouth regions of the face rather than other parts of the face. And as humans, these are regions that we also focus on. So we could tell just from these, even from these first instances of eye tracking, that they're looking at images of others in similar ways to humans. And I'll say one more point about this that I love in Conno's work is he found that chimpanzees pay much more attention to the mouth region, while bonobos pay more attention to the eye region.
但是，这些大型类人猿怎么能够理解它们所看到的是另一只倭黑猩猩或黑猩猩呢？绝对的。好吧，在对大型类人猿的早期眼动追踪研究中，我的导师、同事兼合作者片野寻行（Fumihiro Kano）博士在他对大型类人猿进行眼动追踪的最初研究中发现，黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩注视他人图像的方式与人类相似。因此，它们非常关注脸部的眼睛区域和嘴巴区域，而不是脸部的其他部分。作为人类，这些也是我们关注的区域。所以仅从这些眼动追踪的最初实例中，我们就可以看出，它们注视他人图像的方式与人类相似。关于这一点，我还要补充一点我非常喜欢片野寻行工作的地方，他发现黑猩猩更关注嘴巴区域，而倭黑猩猩更关注眼睛区域。
like us, humans. As humans, we pay a lot of attention to the eye region. We know that eye contact is very important. We communicate a lot with our eyes. It turns out Bonobos are also really interested in looking at the eyes of other individuals. And so we think that this means that there's something about the way they communicate. There's something important about the eyes for them as well. So we can tell just based on them looking at images of others and tracking their eye movements as they look at these images, that they're at least looking at these images in the same ways as humans or in very similar ways as humans. And then as we see that, as we note, that there are differences in their attentional patterns between different individuals based on their group membership and
就像我们人类一样。作为人类，我们非常关注眼睛区域。我们知道眼神交流非常重要。我们用眼睛进行大量交流。事实证明，倭黑猩猩也非常喜欢看其他个体的眼睛。因此，我们认为这意味着它们的交流方式中存在某种东西。眼睛对它们来说也很重要。因此，仅根据它们注视他人图像并在观看这些图像时追踪它们的眼球运动，我们就可以看出，它们至少是以与人类相同的方式，或者以与人类非常相似的方式在注视这些图像。然后，正如我们所看到的，正如我们所注意到的，由于它们的群体成员身份和……
based on their social relationships, we can tell that they are processing these faces as similar or as a representation of an individual in real life. So when you're showing them Pictures of other apes they would presumably recognize. What's the expression on the face of the photograph? I mean, do you show them like a neutral face, a happy face, an angry face, a frightened face? So in these studies, I show them images of faces with neutral expressions so that there weren't any sort of emotional expressions that may be biasing their attention to one image over the other. Some other researchers like Dr. Mariska Krette and others do explore how emotional expressions bias attention in great AIDS. Often they are interested in negative emotional expressions.
基于它们的社会关系，它们在不同个体之间的注意力模式存在差异，我们可以看出它们将这些面孔处理为相似的，或者是现实生活中个体的表征。因此，当您向它们展示它们可能会认出的其他类人猿的照片时，照片上的面部表情是什么？我的意思是，你给它们看的是中性面孔、快乐面孔、生气面孔还是害怕面孔？在这些研究中，我给它们看的是带有中性表情的面孔表情，这样就不会有任何的情绪表情偏向于它们对一幅图像的注意力超过另一幅图像。其他一些研究人员，如玛丽斯卡·克雷特（Mariska Kret）博士和其他人，则探讨了情绪表情如何偏向大型类人猿的注意力。它们通常对负面情绪表情感兴趣。
But here in this study, we didn't want any emotional expressions to bias their attention to one image over the other. And so we used all neutral expressions in these studies. Now, I'll say one thing that we were worried, one thing that we're always worried about when working with great apes, we're very conscious of when we're working with great apes in studies like these is we don't want to create any adverse effects for them. We don't want it to be harmful for them in any way. And so we, in this study, we were showing them images of their previous groupmates. We didn't want there to be any adverse effects or negative harmful effects. And so we watched very carefully at the beginning of this study to ensure that. that the participants themselves weren't expressing any negative emotions. And they weren't. But what I found and was shocked by is that sometimes the chimpanzees and bonobos in this study, they would be drinking juice as they looked at these images. They would be drinking a bit of diluted juice to help keep their heads still
但在这里，在这项研究中，我们不希望任何情绪表情使它们的注意力偏向一幅图像而非另一幅图像。因此我们在这些研究中都使用了中性表情。现在，我要说一件事，这是我们所担心的，也是我们在研究大型类人猿时一直担心的事，我们在做类似这样的研究时非常关注大型类人猿，我们不想为它们产生任何不良影响。我们绝不想以任何方式对它们有害。因此，在这项研究中，我们向它们展示了它们以前同群伙伴的图像。我们不希望有任何不良影响或消极的有害影响。因此，我们在研究开始时非常仔细地观察，以确保……
in order to ensure the accuracy of our eye tracking recordings. And sometimes when they saw the images of their previous groupmates, they would stop drinking the juice, pull away from the straw, and just stare with their mouths hanging open. And it was fascinating. I had never seen these behaviors before when doing eye tracking studies. And I was amazed and delighted and just praying that their eyes movements were still being recorded, even though they had moved slightly and they were. But I was really fascinated and delighted to see, at least, you know, anecdotally, when watching these.
参与者本身并没有表现出任何负面情绪。他们确实没有。但我发现并感到震惊的是，有时这项研究中的黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩在看这些图像时会喝果汁。它们会喝一点稀释的果汁，以帮助保持头部稳定，从而确保我们的眼动追踪记录的准确性。有时，当它们看到以前同群伙伴的图像时，它们会停止喝果汁，从吸管旁拉开，然后只是张大嘴巴呆呆地看着。这太迷人了。在做眼动追踪研究时，我从未见过这些行为。我感到惊讶、高兴，并一直在祈祷它们的眼球运动仍在被记录，尽管它们稍微移动了一下，而且确实被记录了下来。但我真的很着迷，也很高兴看到，至少（你知道的），在观察这些……
participants in my study that they were showing even some behavioral signs of recognition. Now, I couldn't, until I saw the data, I couldn't say one way or the other, you know, whether we really could capture that recognition. But then once I saw the data, I was thrilled that we were actually capturing a difference in attention and what we think is recognition of these previous groupmates. Now, you purposely did not show them pictures of another groupmate who was maybe an enemy or somebody they just didn't like. We did. We did. Exactly. Yes. So we showed them images of previous groupmates with whom they had positive social interactions and images of previous groupmates with whom they
我研究中的参与者时，他们甚至表现出了一些识别的行为迹象。现在，在看到数据之前，我无法肯定地说（你知道的）我们是否真的能够捕捉到这种识别。但一旦我看到了数据，我感到非常兴奋，因为我们确实捕捉到了注意力的差异，以及我们认为是这些以前同群伙伴的识别。现在，你故意没有向它们展示另一个可能是敌人或它们只是不喜欢的人的同群伙伴的照片？我们有。我们有。完全是这样。是的。所以我们向它们展示了那些与它们有积极社会互动的以前同群伙伴的图像，以及那些与它们……
had more negative interactions. And especially with chimpanzees, but also bonobos, we know that social conflicts are very important in their societies, actually just like in ours. They resolve conflicts with aggression. They use aggression to help form and maintain their dominance hierarchy. And so I thought when designing this study that they actually may pay more attention to individuals with whom they had more negative interactions. But we found exactly the opposite. We found that both chimpanzees and bonobos were paying more attention to previous groupmates with whom they had these positive social interactions. We think that that is because positive social interactions also play a key and fundamental role in chimpanzee and bonobos.
有更多消极互动的以前同群伙伴的图像。特别是对于黑猩猩，还有倭黑猩猩，我们知道社会冲突在它们的社会中非常重要，其实就像在我们的社会中一样。它们用攻击来解决冲突。它们利用攻击来帮助形成和维持它们的统治等级。因此，在设计这项研究时，我原以为它们实际上可能会对那些与它们有更多消极互动的个体给予更多的关注。但我们发现的正好相反。我们发现，黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩都对那些与它们有过这些积极社会互动的以前同群伙伴给予了更多的关注。我们认为这是因为积极的社会互动在黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩中也起着关键和根本的作用。
social lives, that their closest friends, the individuals with whom they interact with the most, these individuals they're grooming with, they're playing with, they're spending the most time in proximity with these individuals, they're spending a lot of time and a lot of quality time with their friends. And we think that for these reasons, that they're spending a lot of time in close proximity with these individuals with whom they had positive social interactions, we think that's actually shaping their long-term memory for these individuals and that they have some especially different recognition of these previous groupmates, of these previous friends.
社会生活，它们最好的朋友，那些与它们互动最多的个体，这些与它们梳理毛发、玩耍、花最多时间与它们保持近距离的个体，它们花了很多时间和很多高质量的时间与它们的朋友在一起。我们认为出于这些原因，它们花了很多时间与这些有过积极社会互动的个体保持近距离，我们认为这实际上在塑造它们对这些个体的长期记忆，并且它们对这些以前的同群伙伴、这些以前的朋友有着某种特别不同的识别。
Recognition between bonobos and chimpanzees, did they differ in any way when they were reacting to someone, an animal they had known? We didn't find any species differences, significant species differences in this. study. We found that the bonobos in our study looked slightly longer at previous groupmates as compared to chimpanzees. We think that maybe because of the institutions where these animals were tested, we tested, the bonobos that we tested had more familiarity with these eye tracking setups, with seeing images on the screen. So it may be because of their experience, they may be recognizing these individuals even more. But we didn't find any significant species differences.
倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩之间的识别，当它们对认识的某个动物做出反应时，它们之间有什么不同吗？在这项研究中，我们没有发现任何物种差异、显著的物种差异。我们发现我们研究中的倭黑猩猩注视以前同群伙伴的时间比黑猩猩略长。我们认为这可能是因为测试这些动物的机构，我们测试的倭黑猩猩对这些眼动追踪设置、对在屏幕上看到图像有更多的熟悉度。因此，可能是因为它们的经验，它们可能更能识别这些个体。但我们没有发现任何显著的物种差异。
Do you get to do some of this work in the field? That's a great question. So I also work with chimpanzees living at a sanctuary in Uganda. It's called the Ingamba Island Chimpanzee sanctuary. And that is a sanctuary that's on an island in the middle of Lake Victoria, off the coast of Antebe. And it's a wonderful sanctuary that rescued a lot of chimpanzees about 25 years ago who were orphaned because of deforestation and poaching. Now here on the sanctuary, what's so special about it is that the majority of the island is lush tropical forests that chimpanzees can roam and range in throughout the day.
你有没有在野外做过一些这样的工作？这是一个很好的问题。我也与生活在乌干达一个庇护所的黑猩猩一起工作。它被称为恩甘巴岛黑猩猩庇护所（Ngamba Island Chimpanzee Sanctuary）。这是一个位于维多利亚湖中间的一个岛屿上的庇护所，位于恩德培海岸附近。这是一个美妙的庇护所，在大约25年前救助了许多因森林砍伐和偷猎而成为孤儿的黑猩猩。现在在这个庇护所里，最特别的是岛上的大部分地区都是郁郁葱葱的热带雨林，黑猩猩全天可以在其中漫游和活动。
At night, they have the option of returning to sleeping rooms, where in the morning then we wake up early and do a few of these behavioral tests with them and cognitive tests with them, and then they're let out back into the forest for the rest of the day. So these are not wild populations of great apes. What we refer to them as semi-wild populations of great apes, that they're ranging in a wild environment for most of the day, but they also then return to sleeping rooms built by humans, and it's where we can also do some cognitive behavioral tests with them, of course, completely non-invasive and not harmful to the animals at all. So this is a really special place because we can actually do some eye tracking with them and other behavioral experiments with them,
到了晚上，它们可以选择返回睡眠室，然后在清晨，我们早早醒来，对它们进行一些行为测试和认知测试，之后它们在当天的剩余时间里被放回森林。因此，这些并不是野生的大型类人猿种群。我们称之为半野生的大型类人猿种群，它们在一天的大部分时间里在野生环境中活动，但它们也会返回人类建造的睡眠室，这也是我们可以对它们进行一些认知行为测试的地方，当然，完全是非侵入性的，对动物完全没有伤害。这是一个非常特殊的地方，因为我们实际上可以对它们进行一些眼动追踪和其它行为实验，
whereas when working with wild populations, we now have to be incredibly thoughtful and considerate about what type of instruments, tools, objects we may be introducing into environments like these because we don't want to disturb these wild populations too much. And so instead, we work with what we call semi-wild populations, where we can get as close to wild as possible, but they are familiar with humans and human objects and different tools. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill,
而在与野生种群合作时，我们现在必须对我们可能引入像这样环境中的仪器、工具、物体类型进行极其深思熟虑和体贴的考虑，因为我们不想过多打扰这些野生种群。因此，我们转而与我们所说的半野生种群合作，在那里我们可以尽可能接近野生，但它们熟悉人类、人类物体和不同的工具。你的夏天从全国家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 烧烤来开启夏季烧烤了，
four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed. at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Price invalid May 14th May 27th.
四燃烧器燃气烤架，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐饮套装进行招待，仅需 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受全网最低价保证。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。
U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost!
仅限美国，有例外情况。详情请参见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你刚说这地方离水只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少？够了。够迷路的了！
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises.
或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你想要的是省钱，而不是惊喜。
It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Lewis about whether any other animals, such as dogs or dolphins, might have long-term social memories. Now, are there other non-human animals that have the same recognition skill?
住哪里很关键。希尔顿，为了每一次入住。我们要稍作休息。回来后，我将与刘易斯博士探讨其他动物（如狗或海豚）是否也可能拥有长期的社会记忆。现在，还有其他非人类动物拥有相同的识别技能吗？
I mean, like some pet owners think that their dogs and cats can remember. people. And you know, you see all these videos on social media where somebody's coming back from a long deployment in the military and they get reunited with the dog after, you know, two years and the dog goes crazy. Is that the same thing that you're seeing in chimpanzees and bonobos or is that a different reaction that we're seeing? Yeah. Those, I love those videos. They make me tear up every time. So I will say, yes, we know that other animals. So we know that pet dogs, Some monkeys like Japanese macaques and elephants, sheep, these animals can remember faces for a few years.
我的意思是，就像一些宠物主人认为他们的狗和猫能记住人一样。你知道的，你在社交媒体上看到所有这些视频，有人从军队长期服役中归来，两年后与狗团聚，狗疯了一样。这和你在黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩身上看到的是一回事吗？还是我们看到的另一种不同的反应？是的。那些，我喜欢那些视频。每次都让我热泪盈眶。所以我要说，是的，我们知道其他动物。因此我们知道宠物狗，一些猴子，如日本猕猴和大象、绵羊，这些动物可以记住面孔几年。
So maybe up to three years is what's typically found in the literature. We know that orangutans also can remember faces for about three-ish years. We know from previous research by Keenan and colleagues that bonobos can recognize the vocal of previous groupmates for up to five and a half years. So they can recognize the voices of their previous groupmates for up to five and a half years. And then I'll say another amazing study found that dolphins can remember the vocalizations of their groupmates for up to 20 years. So a really long time. So we do know that there are some animal species.
所以在文献中通常发现的是最多三年左右。我们知道红毛猩猩也能记住面孔大约三年左右。根据基南（Keenan）及其同事先前的研究，我们知道倭黑猩猩可以识别以前同群伙伴的叫声，长达五年半。所以它们可以识别以前同群伙伴的声音长达五年半。然后我要说另一项惊人的研究发现，海豚可以记住它们同群伙伴的发声长达20年。所以时间真的很长。所以我们确实知道有一些动物物种。
And there are many animal species that can remember the faces or. the vocalizations of previous groupmates for a few years. And then we've only found in a few species like dolphins that they can remember vocalizations for two decades. And the last thing I'll say is that the only other study that we know of that really has found that social relationships shape long-term memory in non-human animals is with ravens. And that was found with Corvids that their social relationships do affect their long-term social memory as well. That's the only other study besides this one where we find that social relationships are impacting social memory as they do in humans.
而且有许多动物物种可以记住以前同群伙伴的面孔或发声几年。然后我们只在少数物种（如海豚）中发现它们可以记住发声长达二十年。我要说的最后一件事是，我们所知的唯一另一项真正发现社会关系会塑造非人类动物长期记忆的研究是对渡鸦进行的。研究发现，鸦科动物（Corvids）的社会关系确实也会影响它们的长期社会记忆。这是除本研究之外唯一一项发现社会关系像在人类中一样影响社会记忆的研究。
What made you glom onto bonobos and chimpanzees? Why not some other great apes? Yeah, that's a great question. I have been studying bonobos and chimpanzees for 13 years, and I find them fascinating, precisely because they are so similar to us. They are our closest living cousins, and they are so similar to us in many ways, and I think especially in their social environments.
是什么让你对倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩情有独钟？为什么不是其他一些大型类人猿？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我研究倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩已经13年了，我发现它们非常迷人，正是因为它们与我们太相似了。它们是我们现存最近的表亲，它们在许多方面与我们非常相似，我认为尤其是在它们的社会环境中。
These individuals, these species, can live in groups of up to 150, sometimes even 200 individuals in a single community. So they live in these large communities, like we do as humans, But these communities aren't together at all times of the day. They have what we call fission fusion social systems. So smaller groups will break off from the community and they will go and forage on their own.
这些个体、这些物种可以生活在多达150人、有时甚至200个个体的单个社群中。所以它们生活在这些大型社群中，就像我们人类一样，但这些社群并不是一天中的所有时间都在一起。它们拥有我们所谓的裂变-融合社会系统。因此，较小的群体会从社群中分离出来，它们会自己去觅食。
Or a group of male chimpanzees may go and patrol the borders of their territory. And so they will break off. This is the fission part of their social dynamics. And then at other times of the day, they'll come back together, let's say at a big fruiting tree. and especially at night, they'll come back together for safety at night into bigger groups. And this is called the fusion part of their social system. So they have these fascinating fission fusion social dynamics. Again, just like we do as humans, right?
或者一群雄性黑猩猩可能会去巡视它们领土的边界。所以它们会分裂出去。这是它们社会动态的裂变部分。然后在一天的其他时间，它们会重新聚在一起，比如说在一棵长满果实的大树旁。尤其是在晚上，它们会为了晚上的安全重新聚成更大的群体。这就是它们社会系统的融合部分。所以它们拥有这些迷人的裂变-融合社会动态。同样，就像我们人类一样，对吧？
This is the same type of social dynamics that chimpanzees have bonobo's experience as well. And this is why I'm so drawn to study their social psychology. I want to talk about another one of your recent studies. you found that both human children and chimps like to watch social interactions. That's right. What else did you find in that study? Tell us about that one. Yeah.
这就是黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩也经历的相同类型的社会动态。这就是为什么我如此被吸引去研究它们的社会心理学。我想谈谈你的另一项最新研究。你发现人类儿童和黑猩猩都喜欢观看社会互动。没错。你在那项研究中还发现了什么？给我们讲讲那个吧。是的。
So this is a fun study. Now, instead of using eye tracking techniques here, I designed a new kind of paradigm or method that I call the curiosity boxes. So here what I'm studying is social curiosity, curiosity being the drive or the motivation to gain information. And so what I wanted to study here is often curiosity is studied in physical context. So curiosity about an object and what it may do, curiosity about the location of a hiding reward. But here, I wanted to study social curiosity, so the drive to gain social information.
所以这是一个有趣的研究。现在，这里不再使用眼动追踪技术，而是设计了一种我称之为好奇心盒子的全新范式或方法。所以这里我研究的是社会好奇心，好奇心是获得信息的驱动力或动机。所以我在这里想要研究的是，好奇心通常是在物理背景下进行研究的。因此，对物体及其可能作用的好奇，对隐藏奖励位置的好奇。但在这里，我想研究社会好奇心，也就是获取社会信息的驱动力。
And what I was really interested in is whether children and chimpanzees demonstrate similar social curiosity or not. So I designed these curiosity boxes, which are two wooden boxes placed on tables spaced about three feet a meter apart. And inside these boxes are tablets with videos playing on them. And I designed them both for children and chimpanzees. There is a handle on the door of the box that they could slide up and a vertically sliding door would slide up so that children and chimpanzees could look inside and watch these videos. And importantly, they had to keep holding the door up in order to keep watching the videos. As soon as they let go of the door, the door would drop down and they could no longer access these videos. And so what we think
我真正感兴趣的是儿童和黑猩猩是否表现出相似的社会好奇心。所以我设计了这些好奇心盒子，它们是放置在桌子上的两个木盒子，相距大约三英尺（一米）。这些盒子里面是播放视频的平板电脑。我为儿童和黑猩猩都设计了这些盒子。盒子的门上有一个把手，它们可以向上滑动，垂直滑动门会向上滑动，以便儿童和黑猩猩可以往里面看并观看这些视频。重要的是，它们必须一直按住门才能继续观看视频。一旦它们松开门，门就会掉下来，它们就再也无法观看这些视频了。所以我们认为……
we're measuring here is a measure of curiosity, that there's this drive or this motivation to continue holding the door up and gaining the information inside. Now, importantly, the videos inside are videos of social interactions in one box versus non-social interactions in another box, or just a single individual in the other box. So we had videos of social interactions. Children would see videos of other children interacting. Chimpanzees would see videos of chimpanzees interacting. And we had them in different contexts like playing and grooming, etc.
我们在这里测量的是好奇心的量度，即继续按住门并获取里面信息的这种驱动力或动机。现在，重要的是，里面的视频是一个盒子里的社会互动视频，而另一个盒子里的则是非社会互动视频，或者另一个盒子里仅仅是一个单独的个体。所以我们有社会互动视频。儿童会看到其他儿童互动的视频。黑猩猩会看到黑猩猩互动的视频。我们将它们置于不同的背景下，比如玩耍和梳理毛发等。
we found that both children and chimpanzees looked significantly longer at the videos of the social interactions as compared to the videos of a single agent acting alone. And we think that they're actually attentive to how much social information is in each of these videos, that a video of a single agent is just all the information you can get is just about that individual alone. Whereas with the videos of the social interactions, not only can you gain information about two different individuals, but you can also gain some information about their relationship as well. And so we think that chimpanzees and children are attentive to these differences in amount of social information, and they're drawn or they're motivated to go and gain more social information from these social interactions.
我们发现儿童和黑猩猩注视社会互动视频的时间明显长于注视单个单独行动的代理人视频的时间。我们认为它们实际上在关注这些视频中包含多少社会信息，单个代理人的视频所能获得的所有信息都只是关于该个体本身的。而在社会互动视频中，你不仅可以获得关于两个不同个体的信息，还可以获得一些关于他们关系的信息。因此，我们认为黑猩猩和儿童都在关注社会信息量的这些差异，并且它们被吸引或有动机去这些社会互动中获取更多的社会信息。
And were these social interactions, for the most part, positive? In other words, you weren't showing them videos of people or animals fighting with each other, were you? We actually were. Uh-huh. Yes. So, yes, in another study around the same time, we had positive social interactions in one box versus negative social interactions in another box. So the positive interactions were things like playing or grooming. For chimpanzees, that's really where they're grooming one another.
这些社会互动在很大程度上是积极的吗？换句话说，你没有给它们看人或动物互相打架的视频吧？我们确实看了。呃-哼。是的。所以，是的，在大约同一时间的另一项研究中，我们在一个盒子中有积极的社会互动，而在另一个盒子中有消极的社会互动。因此，积极的互动是诸如玩耍或梳理毛发之类的事情。对于黑猩猩来说，那真的是它们互相梳理毛发的地方。
For children, that's where they're doing each other's hair, for example. And in the other box, we had videos of conflicts. Now, for chimpanzees, that was actual videos of conflicts, so physical, aggressive fights between two chimpanzees. Whereas for the kids, we didn't want to show them videos of children beating each other up. And so instead, we took videos from YouTube. where children were, for example, playing tug of war or fighting over a toy. So they weren't, you know, aggressive and violent videos, but there was some conflict involved.
对于儿童来说，那是他们互相弄头发的地方，例如。而在另一个盒子里，我们有冲突的视频。现在，对于黑猩猩来说，那是真实的冲突视频，也就是两只黑猩猩之间身体上的、具攻击性的打斗。而对于孩子们，我们不想给他们看孩子们互相殴打的视频。因此，我们从 YouTube 上获取了视频。
Now, interestingly, we found that chimpanzees did not show any significant differences in their curiosity for positive versus negative social interactions. But we found something fascinating with the children. We found that at four years old, both girls and boys at four years old were somewhat more curious about positive social interactions. As they aged, boys and girls split in terms of their curiosity. Girls became more and more curious about positive social interactions, whereas boys became more and more curious about negative social interactions, such that by age six, we saw that by age six, we saw. see a significant difference in their social curiosity, where boys are watching these videos of negative conflicts significantly more than our girls, and girls are watching the videos of the positive social interactions significantly more than our boys. I want to talk about one
孩子们在那里，例如，在玩拔河比赛或者为玩具争吵。所以它们不是（你知道的）攻击性和暴力的视频，但其中涉及一些冲突。现在有趣的是，我们发现黑猩猩对积极与消极社会互动的好奇心没有表现出任何显着的差异。但我们在儿童身上发现了一个迷人的现象。我们发现，在四岁时，四岁的女孩和男孩对积极的社会互动都有些许更多的好奇心。随着年龄的增长，男孩和女孩在好奇心方面出现了分歧。女孩对积极社会互动的好奇心变得越来越强，而男孩对消极社会互动的好奇心变得越来越强，以至于到六岁时，我们看到……到六岁时，我们看到了。看到他们的社会好奇心有显着差异，男孩观看这些消极冲突视频的显着多于女孩，而女孩观看积极社会互动视频的显着多于男孩。我想谈谈这个发现的一个有趣的部分，
interesting piece of this finding, though, which is the time at which girls and boys split. So we see the time at which they split is right around five years old. And this is a very important time for kids in the U.S. at least. This is right around the time that they're entering school. So we think that they are now, at age five, they are starting to be socialized as girls and socialized as boys more and more by their teachers, by the other adults in the schools, by their peers as well. So I think that what may be happening here, what may be driving these patterns of social curiosity is a combination of factors. I think it's a thing. a combination of evolutionary selective pressures. It is certainly the case that boys and men
然而，那就是女孩和男孩分化的时间。所以我们看到他们分化的时间大约在五岁左右。对于美国的儿童来说，这是一个非常重要的时间，至少是这样。这大约是他们开始上学的时间。所以我们认为，他们在五岁时，开始越来越多地被老师、学校里的其他成年人以及同龄人社会化为女孩和男孩。所以我认为这里可能发生的事情，可能在推动这些社会好奇心模式的，是多种因素的组合。我认为这是一件事。演化选择压力的组合。男孩和男人确实如此……
had to be more attentive to conflicts and were more involved in conflicts throughout our evolutionary history, in physical conflicts throughout our evolutionary history. But also, I think that it's also a huge factor here, maybe the socialization patterns and the differences in how we socialize girls and boys. So I think it's a combination of socialization patterns and evolutionary patterns as well that may be shaping social curiosity differently in girls versus boys. What are the biggest challenges in working with non-human primates? That's a wonderful question. And since this is a podcast all about psychology, I'll talk a little bit about the psychology of these apes and trying to understand what they may be
在我们的进化史中，必须对冲突更加警觉，并且更多地卷入冲突，在身体冲突方面也是如此。但同时，我认为这也是一个巨大的影响因素，也许社交模式以及我们在社会化女孩和男孩方式上的差异也是原因之一。因此，我认为社交模式和进化模式的结合，可能以不同的方式塑造了女孩和男孩的好奇心。与非人类灵灵长类动物合作面临的最大挑战是什么？这是一个极好的问题。既然这是一个关于心理学的播客，我将谈谈这些类人猿的心理，并试图了解它们的想法。
thinking. I think that's the biggest challenge. Of course, they're dangerous. And so we have to be very conscious of working with them just physically because they're very strong. They're very strong. They're very strong. And they can be aggressive, not always, but they can be. So that's one challenge. But I would say the biggest challenge when trying to study the minds of these great apes is how do you get at their inner worlds, their inner workings. Now, this is a question that I, or this is a challenge that I share with developmental psychologists who work with infants. We can't just ask infants questions and then have them answer, right? Instead, we have to get creative and come up with designs where we can ask them questions in these creative ways. So we're not verbally asking them
思考。我认为这是最大的挑战。当然，它们很危险。因此，我们在与它们合作时必须非常注意身体安全，因为它们非常强壮。它们非常强壮。它们非常强壮。而且它们可能会具有攻击性，虽然不总是这样，但确实有可能。所以这是一个挑战。但我想说，在试图研究这些大型类人猿的心智时，最大的挑战是如何探究它们的内心世界和内心运作机制。现在，这个问题或挑战是我与研究婴儿的发展心理学家所共有的。我们不能直接问婴儿问题然后让他们回答，对吧？相反，我们需要发挥创造力，设计出能够以这种创造性方式向他们提问的方案。所以我们不是在口头上问他们
questions and asking them to verbally respond. But instead, we're designing different games and different techniques and different methods in order to measure their behavior on these tasks, that then where we can actually, based on their behavior, we can test some hypotheses about what may be happening in their minds. So just as with infants, we can't just ask chimpanzees and bonobos, hey, what do you think about this individual? Do you find this more interesting? Do you remember this guy from 10 years ago?
问题并要求他们用言语回应。相反，我们在设计不同的游戏、不同的技术和不同的方法，以便在这些任务中衡量他们的行为，然后我们可以根据他们的行为来测试一些关于他们心智中可能发生的事情的假设。因此，就像对待婴儿一样，我们不能直接问黑猩猩和小倭黑猩猩：嘿，你对这个人怎么看？你觉得这个人更有趣吗？你还记得10年前的这家伙吗？
Instead, we have to design these creative games and methodologies in order to understand and try and answer some of these questions. So it's both the biggest challenge for me when working with Great Apes and also the biggest joy. I love trying to be creative when trying to understand something about the minds of our closest cousins where we can't just ask them a question or ask them to fill out a survey. Right. So big picture, what does studying chimps and bonobos social cognition teach us about human abilities and how they evolved? Absolutely. Well, I was trained in departments that asked this question. What makes humans unique?
相反，我们必须设计这些创新的游戏和方法，以便理解并试图回答其中一些问题。因此，这既是我在与大型类人猿合作时面临的最大挑战，也是最大的乐趣。当我试图了解我们最亲近的表亲的心智时，我喜欢尝试发挥创造力，而我们却不能直接向他们提问或让他们填写问卷。没错。那么从宏观来看，研究黑猩猩和小倭黑猩猩的社会认知能教给我们关于人类能力及其进化过程的什么知识呢？当然。我在提出这个问题的部门接受过培训。是什么让人类独一无二？
Often the question comes from, what is so special about humans? What makes us so special? I instead am much more focused on another question, a similar but different question, which is, what makes humans so similar to our great ape cousins? And I think this is the question that I continuously try to answer in my work, is how similar are we? Are we curious about the same things? Does our memory last the same amount of time?
通常这个问题源于：人类有什么特别之处？是什么让我们如此特别？相反，我更关注另一个问题，一个相似但不同的问题，那就是：是什么让人类与我们的大型类人猿表亲如此相似？我认为这就是我在工作中不断试图回答的问题：我们有多相似？我们对相同的事物感到好奇吗？我们的记忆持续的时间是一样的吗？
Do our friendships matter in the same way to us? do we think about individuals in the same way? And of course, then from there, also what may be different, but I'm much more fascinated by the question of what makes humans so similar to our great ape cousins? And so by studying chimpanzees and bonobos and humans in comparison, I can think about the, and test hypotheses about the selective pressures that have shaped our social cognition in similar or differing ways.
我们的友谊对我们的重要性是否相同？我们看待个体的方式是否相同？当然，在此基础上，可能还有哪些不同之处，但我更着迷于这个问题：是什么通过将黑猩猩、小倭黑猩猩和人类进行比较，我可以思考并测试关于塑造我们社会认知方向的相似或不同选择压力的假设。
So we can think about the evolutionary history and the time, the five million years since we split, since, you know, we split from these species. And we can think about the different selective and evolutionary pressures that we've faced. For example, we have continued to evolve in large social groups. That means we need to be able to identify, discriminate between, recognize, and remember other individuals in our groups for years. However, for example, Bonobos evolved to have females be the most dominant members of their groups. So this is an evolutionary pressure that is very specific for them in terms of their social dominance and the individuals who hold the highest roles in their dominance hierarchy. For humans, that may be a little bit different, right? For chimpanzees, that's also different. Chimpanzees are male dominant, right? So I like to think about what are the similarities between humans and our closest cousins,
因此，我们可以思考进化历史和时间，即自从我们分化以来，也就是我们从这些物种中分化出来的五百万年。我们可以思考我们所面临的不同选择和进化压力。例如，我们继续在大型社会群体中进化。这意味着我们需要能够识别、区分、辨认和记住我们群体中的其他个体，并且持续多年。然而，例如，小倭黑猩猩进化出了由雌性作为其群体中最具统治地位成员的特征。因此，这是一种对它们而言非常特殊的进化压力，体现在它们的社会统治地位以及在其统治等级中占据最高角色的个体上。对人类来说，情况可能有点不同，对吧？对黑猩猩来说，这也是不同的。黑猩猩是雄性统治的，对吧？所以我喜欢思考人类与我们最亲近的表亲之间有哪些相似之处，
and then also what are the differences? And what are the evolutionary pressures that have shaped these similarities and differences in our social psychology? So what's next for you? What are you working on now? What are the big questions you want to answer? Yes. Well, this is an extremely exciting time and chapter in my life. I've just started as an assistant professor at UC Santa Barbara, and I've just started my very own lab.
然后还有哪些不同之处？塑造我们社会心理中这些相似性和差异性的进化压力又是什么？那么你接下来有什么打算？你现在在研究什么？你想回答的重大问题是什么？是的。这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻，也是我人生中的一个新篇章。我刚开始担任加州大学圣巴巴拉分校的助理教授，并且刚刚建立了我自己的实验室。
It's called the Boom Lab, the biological origins of mind lab. And I have my first PhD student, Amanda Goggin, along with six undergraduate research assistants who are helping to start new research with chimpanzees at the Los Angeles Zoo. So we're just getting started. We're just getting started with some of these projects, but I'm very excited to bring some of these. of this research to the Southern California area to start this own research with my lab and to start exploring some new aspects of social psychology, including around friendships with new mothers and their infants and how different social relationships may affect interactions with new infants in the community. That all sounds really exciting. Well, Dr. Lewis, I want to thank you for joining me and
它叫做“布姆实验室”（Boom Lab），即心智的生物学起源实验室。我有我的第一位博士生阿曼达·高金（Amanda Goggin），还有六名本科生研究助理，他们正在帮助洛杉矶动物园开展关于黑猩猩的新研究。所以我们才刚刚开始。我们刚刚开始着手其中一些项目，但我非常高兴能将其中一些研究带到南加州地区，在我的实验室开展这项自主研究，并开始探索社会心理学的新方面，包括围绕新妈妈与其婴儿之间的友谊，以及不同的社会关系如何影响社区内与新婴儿的互动。听起来真的很令人兴奋。刘博士，我要感谢你参加我的节目，并
wish you luck in your future research. Thank you so much for having me. It's been a joy to talk to you. Thank you, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app,
祝你未来的研究一切顺利。非常感谢邀请我。与你交谈非常愉快。谢谢你，金。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目，也可以在苹果、声田、YouTube 或任何你收听播客的地方找到。如果你喜欢你所听到的话，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫斯（Ralph's）享受更多省钱方式，例如每个货架都有的低价。当你下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，
you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪裁并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油时每加仑可节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫斯，每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天大省特省总是那么轻松。拉尔夫斯南加州服务超过150年。省钱金额可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请见网站。本集目前尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。